The optimist will see this cup half full, while the pessimist will confirm it is half empty.
Of course, others will note that it is full of atoms
That water, air and others will remind you that 99.99% of the atoms are empty space
Making the cup ... often empty! But seriously, science can explain
Your emotional perspective and your outlook on life?
It turned out that it was not under your control. Research has shown that those who have long allele (a contrasting genetic dye qualities)
In serotonin-specific genes, they are more prone to focus on the positive side of life
As someone who enjoys ice cream - compared to those with short alleles
The more inclined to focus on the downside of life - as someone who has been robbed
The difference in oxytocin receptor gene can affect your perspective, individuals with two copies of guanine
They were observed to be more positive with higher self confidence, while those
Who have two copies of adenine are less positive. So people seem to be genetically affected
For pessimism.
Interestingly, positives are less likely to be hypnotized in hospital after coronary bypass surgery
Achieve higher academic achievements, and even better economic and social conditions
But not all of them are good, they exaggerate their abilities and are at risk.
Pessimists, on the other hand, have a more realistic perspective of the world and are more cautious when they plan
The future has been living longer. In a historical study spanning 20 years it was found that
Pessimists use a cautious approach to their health and financial resources, avoiding dangerous behavior
Such as smoking and excessive drinking, in the end they are finally laughing - on the positive -
But we are statistically positive, known as "positive bias"
Located in about 80% of the population, we tend to exaggerate the probability
Positive events in the future, and underestimated the likelihood of adverse events.
For example, despite the high rate of divorce for nearly 40% of most newlyweds
They estimate the probability of being separated 0%. Possibly you imagine your future
- Often - better than your current situation. And above all, we usually imagine ourselves
Smarter, more social, and more honest than others.
When we look at the brain, in fact we see that the left part shows a greater activity
When you imagine positive things, while during bad events the activity of the right half rises
But at a lower rate, this indicates that the brain chooses to ignore
The negative information is filtered and focuses on the positive.
Our view is, whether you are genetically engineered to see the cup half full
Or half empty - to tell the water and drink only if you allow!
This actually reminds us of the famous saying "Giving better than taking"
But is this scientifically true? We have answered this in AsapTHOUGHT
With special gifts where you can click the link here or in the description box
To inspect them. Special thanks for audible for their support of this episode
And give you free audio books on audible.com/asap this week we would like to nominate you
This book 'The Wright Brothers' is a wonderful story about the two brothers
Note the world how to fly - while staying positive during all the challenges you face!
You can get a free copy via audible.com/asap or any book of your choice
From our group. We love it because it will be suitable when you are on the wheel of your order.
Do not forget to ask your urgent questions, and subscribe to more weekly scientific sections.
(: